hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and i am so excited
because today starts the 2021 world
chess championships we have been waiting
three years for this tournament it is
finally here i'm gonna give an
introduction into the tournament and
then we'll go ahead and jump into
game number one so this tournament last
was played in 2018
madness carlson defended his
championship against fabiana carawanna
was supposed to be last year but with
the pandemic it was delayed until this
year it also meant that the canada's
tournament
it's kind of a
two-year span to figure out who's going
to play in the candidates tournament
winner of the kansas tournament goes on
to play the defending champion
that got stretched out to two years as
well so there was a break after 2020
they played the second half earlier in
2021 and jan nepo
was the winner of that tournament so he
goes on to face magnus carlson for the
world championship this is in dubai this
is going to be a best of 14 series
meaning that the first one to seven and
a half points you get one point for
winning you get half a point for a draw
so first one to seven and a half points
is going to be victorious they are gonna
play three days on then they're gonna
take a rest day they're gonna play two
days on and then they're gonna repeat
that so rest day three days rest day two
days rest and then so on and so forth so
the time control 120 minutes for the
first 40 moves after that they're gonna
get 60 minutes
and then after 20 more moves they're
gonna get 15 minutes added on for the
rest of the game so your typical
classical chess and these players have
actually met 13 times before in
classical chess and if you remember any
of my coverage of the candidates
tournament head yon nepo is probably the
most qualified person to beat magnus
carlson in classical chess because
they've played 13 times magnus carlsen's
only won one of those there were eight
draws
and jan nepo actually won four of those
so he knows what it takes to beat manage
crossing now i do think madness carlson
in a long series like the world
championship
is better than anyone out there maybe
better than anyone that's ever played
the game he can really just grind down
his opponents and it's very very
difficult to find an edge on him so this
is gonna be a fantastic
series we're gonna have coverage of
every single match be going over the
highlights uh some of the interesting
spots that i found uh give you my own
commentaries hopefully you guys enjoy
watching this so without further ado
let's go ahead and jump into
game number one of the 2021 world chess
championships
so starting with the white pieces in
game number one is jan nepo i'm just
going to be referring to him as nepo
throughout this video and then magnus
carlson playing the black pieces so
starts out with the rye lopez e4
e5 not f3 knight c6 we see bishop here
to
b5 and then we get into a6 bishop comes
back here to a4 so getting into the
closed defense after knight two f6 here
we see castle on the king side bishop to
e7 so more of a traditional approach
from magnus carlsen typically now you'll
see the bishop coming out to c5
just more of an active square for the
bishop than coming here to e7 which you
know for a hundred years prior to you
know maybe 10 20 years ago this was the
preferred move just bishop here to e7 so
madness carlson kind of going back to
the the old school approach at bishop
here to e7 preparing to castle on the
king side here rook 2e1
defending this pawn here on e4 and then
after pawn to b5 bishop back here to b3
and then castle on the king side and
this is where it's always interesting in
these tournaments you know these players
have teams that they're focused on
helping them prepare for these
tournaments they're studying different
variations figuring out what's going to
work against their opponents
and so it's always intriguing to see how
they are going to approach different
openings
against their opponents and in this case
you know you typically see
a marshall attack here with something
like c3 pawn to d5 here uh but we see
nepo going with the anti-marshall and
that is pawn to h3 says yeah you're not
gonna play d5 right now we can just uh
take here and eventually just play
knight here to c3
and this is where
we start to see a
kind of shift from your your main line
that you would typically see and so uh
this is the the first time in the match
that magnus cross and actually took some
time every move up to this point only
took him about five six seconds uh but
madness carlson took about two minutes
to figure out okay how he wanted to play
against this h3 move not your typical
main line that you see
but no worries he he decides to play
knight to a5 attacking this bishop here
on uh b3
knight takes here on e5
knight takes here on b3 pawn sake so uh
we have a small exchange here uh bishop
here to b7
pawn here to uh d3 and then pawn d5 and
after the exchange here uh queen 2 f3
and then bishop to d6 now this is an
interesting
variation that madness carlson decided
to go on after knight to a5 he decides
to go ahead and give up material so
neither side right now has given up any
material decides to go ahead and give up
that pawn here on e5 there's the
exchange right here on uh b3 and magnus
carlsen does not get that pawn back that
he gave up here on e5 so bishop here to
b7 but then this defended by d3 also
opens up for the dark square bishop to
get involved for nepo pawn to d5 there
is the exchange right there and so
madness carlson after queen f3 bishop
here to d6 says hey i'm okay giving up
that pawn
in exchange for a bishop pair so that's
always going to be extremely powerful
and the double pawn here on the b file
so a lot of people always ask you what
separates these top top players from
others and it's this ability to give up
material for
a long-term game there's no immediate
threat that madness carlson has yes he's
going to be able to control the center
of the board a little bit better and he
does have the bishop pair but he's
thinking long term
how the positions of the pawn structures
and how this board could take a turn in
different directions and how magnus
carlsen actually thinks he can uh fare
better even though he gave up that pawn
so from here we see king to f1 yes we
could have seen in exchange maybe queen
takes here on d5 knight takes maybe
bishop here to d2 uh but nepo decides to
go ahead and play king to
f1 here and then rook over here to b8
this rook here on a8 is controlling this
pawn here on a6 so if there's ever any
sort of exchange here on b7 this bishop
would no longer be able to hold on to it
so wants to make sure right now at least
that this rook is holding on to it so
decides to bring his rook over here to
ba to protect that now we do see an
exchange in the center of the board
queen takes here on d5 knight takes
bishop here to d2
and then after pawn to c5 we have the
knight come back here to f3
now just to show you some of the threats
that madness crossing had if we come
back a few moves here
and start to see instead of the
the queen taking here uh maybe nepo
decides to
build up more of his pieces in the
center of the board maybe bishop here to
f4 says hey madness carlson has a lot of
peaches pieces controlling the center of
the board i want to get some pieces
involved into the center as well
but this gets very difficult for white
to hold on to there's always the
discovered attack after the queen moves
bishop here to b7 now attacking this
queen on f3 so the queen's got to get
out of harm's way here maybe queen down
here to d4 this is attacking this bishop
here on f4 as well as the pawn here on
b2 so i really just need the bishop to
move and then queen takes here on
b2 so magnus is really controlling the
center of the board and there's no way
for nepo to really counter attack that
and so in this position he did just
decide correctly to go ahead and
exchange uh just because madness had too
much of a presence in the center and you
know obviously if you're up a pond and
material it tends to fare better for you
if you just exchange down a material
closer you can get to the in-game with a
material advantage that's going to be
better for you than if your opponent has
all of their major pieces attacking and
controlling the center of the board
so after knight to f3 here we see the
rook come back here to d8 no longer has
to protect this bishop here on v7
there's not going to be an exchange
variation where
that is going to fall here on
b7 so knight to c3 quickly met by knight
to uh b4 looking at this the the bishop
is no longer able to attack this knight
here on b4 uh this pawn here can't just
come up to c3 so very easy uh way for
madness carlson to come here attack this
pawn and if he ever wants to maneuver
the knight around the board this is one
way to do that as well rook here to c1
defending the pawn here on c2 decides to
go and bring his rook over here to c8
then knight to
e2 opening up for the bishop to attack
the knight here on b4 knight comes back
here to
c6 bishop here to e3 attacking this pawn
but that's fine this bishop is doing a
good job of defending that pawn here
knight comes back here to e7 so you can
see madness just trying to maneuver his
knight around the board bishop's doing a
good job of still controlling much of
the center of the board here bishop here
to f4 this is where i think magnus
carlsen decides you know what i really
don't have a strong attack so i'm gonna
go ahead and trade down and then see if
i can get either a draw here or my
opponent can make a mistake because
remember part of the reason he gave up a
pawn he only has six pawns his opponent
has seven so his opponent does have a
material advantage is because madness
carlson had a strong central presence
and he had the bishop pair madness
carlson in this spot decides to go ahead
and exchange off but after the exchange
he is allowing his opponent now to have
two double pawns both on the b file as
well as the f file and on the f file
there's no
connecting pawn so there's not a pawn on
the e file or the g file so this is
going to be a pretty difficult way for
white to try to hold on to all of the
pawns so if you look at it and say uh
yeah going into the end game white has a
pawn advantage while that is true it is
definitely gonna be hard for him to
control and maintain that advantage
especially against magnus carlsen so
although magnus is down a pawn and
material actually it feels like he is uh
the the one that has the best shot of
breaking through now after the bishop
from b7 came down in exchange this pawn
here on a6 was left hanging so after
this exchange on f4 completes the
exchange then we do see the rook come
down here to c6 does need to maintain
control of this a6 square because the
rook here on a1 is still attacking it
nepal continues with rook here to e1
controlling the open e file knight comes
down here to
f5 pawn to c3 right over here to
h4 this knight here on f5 was preparing
to come over here to d4 potentially and
attack this pawn here on f3 the pawn
here on c3 stops the knight from coming
here but magnus carlsen decides yeah i
can just come over here to h4 and attack
this same pawn here so that's fine rook
here to
e3
just getting it to a more central square
also defending not only uh controlling
this e file but now defending this
square here on f3 but that you can start
to see
uh some of the the vulnerabilities that
white has in the position these double
pawns on the same file are very
difficult to hold on to and so you start
to have to use some of your other pieces
potentially your king to really hold on
to that material or madness carlson can
really start to chip away
get back one of those pawns and then
have a strong attack so king here to f8
once the queens come off the board you
typically want to get your kings
involved into the game that's exactly
what we see madness carlson starting to
do here knight comes back here to g2
knight here to f5 attacking the rook
what comes up here to e5 uh pawn here to
g6 just supporting this knight so a nice
little outpost here on f5 here uh not
going to be able to kick this knight
away because remember there's no pawns
here on the g file for white and there's
no pawns here on the e file so you can
just hang out here all day if magnus
carlsen really wants to decides right
now to come back to knight to g7 rook
here to e4 and then pawn to f5 you know
it's very difficult for white to really
figure out how does nepo continue and
improve his position uh you know rook to
e4
i don't think it does too much but i
don't really know where he could go that
would be an improvement uh pawn to f5 so
does develop and have uh tempo uh just
forcing his opponent to come back he
could just played rook here to e3 to
begin with uh but that's fine knight
here to e6 both these players you know
we're at 32 moves right now and they
didn't have a ton of time so part of
this is always just slightly trying to
improve your position but also getting
to move 40 so that you can get an
additional hour of time
because at this point i think they only
had maybe 15 or so minutes left so don't
have a ton of time on the clock here
knight here to g2
b4 so starting to attack on the queen
side of the board very important to hold
on pressure for
this c5 square because
you never want your opponent to bring
their knight here to
b4 and attack this pawn over here on a6
that would put two attackers here so you
just don't want to have to worry about
that so that's something to think about
from magnus crossing standpoint you want
to control this c5 square here uh king 2
e2
rook over here to b8 says yeah if you
take with your pawn i want to make sure
i can take with my rook here i don't
want to have to take with my pawn here
king here to d2 decides to go and take
it with his own pawn so yes the pawn can
recapture here
but remember you can start to see some
of the vulnerabilities of those double
pawns now the rook can come down take
here on b3 so it took magnus carlson
over 24-ish moves around there to get
that material back but eventually he
does you can see he's always thinking of
the long game here and so he has a
pretty good position i feel like if
anyone is going to win this it could be
magnus carlsen here he both sides equal
in material but you can see white still
has the double pawns here on the f file
um the
black pawns are a little bit more
connected especially on the king side uh
three pawn chains that i don't think
fare nearly as well from white
standpoint so uh madness carlson i think
has the slight advantage still going to
be very difficult for him to turn this
into a victory king here to c2 attacking
the rook comes back to b7 pawn up here
to h4 says yeah i need to start to
attack on the king side chip away at
this pawn structure from black here king
2 f7 rook down here to e1 king to f6
just centralizing that king a little bit
and now we get into the 40th move so
after 93
and then
rook over here to d7 they do get an
extra hour of time here so at this point
you're kind of thinking you know i don't
know how this is going to continue uh
maybe we see a lot of pressure from
madness carlson and we could see a very
long game we have definitely seen
madness crosston play these really
really long games to try to wear out his
opponent you just never know exactly
what you're going to get in these games
but we see knight 2 c4 rook over here to
e7
knight to e5 rook here 2 d6
and then we see some repeating of move
so knight to c4 rook to c6 here and then
we see
just a repetition and both sides decide
hey after 45 moves we are going to
draw so
game number one is in the books and we
see a draw which i think from magnus
carlsen's standpoint you start with the
black pieces
that is going to be a success in his
mind and if you watch the post game
interview with him he seemed pretty
relaxed you know he seemed like he was
in good spirits uh both players were
joking around a bit it was good to see
them uh both enjoying the moment it's
gonna be a fun series i feel like in the
first game here they were both filling
each other out played some interesting
new variations that we don't typically
see so i thought that was good i thought
nepo came very well prepared i just
thought madness carlson defended
extremely well today and did not allow
nepo to to really do anything that i
think he was probably preparing to do
but all in all great first game
hopefully you guys enjoyed game number
one hopefully you're excited for this
entire series let me know in the
comments below uh what your thoughts are
on the series who you think is going to
win and what you're most excited about
so thank you guys again for watching and
i'll see you guys tomorrow for game
number two